ce dossier ukrainien qui sera aussi au
coeur d'une rencontre aujourd'hui à
berlin entre le président français
emmanuel macron et le nouveau chancelier
allemand olaf scholz tous deux devraient
tenter d'adopter une position commune
face à moscou mais le successeur
d'angela merkel est à la tête d'une
coalition très divisé sur le sujet à
berlin on retrouve anne mahieu notre
correspondante
le parti social démocrate allemand
invoque très volontiers la tradition de
lost politique de vibrantes une
politique de rapprochement avec l'urss
dans les années
1970 et puis bien évidemment la
perspective même que des armes
allemandes puisse à nouveau être utilisé
contre des soldats russes après la
seconde guerre mondiale or est
difficilement envisageable pour de très
nombreux allemands mais au-delà de ça il
y à aussi bien sur des intérêts
économiques
l'allemagne est très dépendante des
importations de gaz russe et la question
du gazoduc north stream 2 qui relie la
russie à l'allemagne en est la parfaite
illustration
washington et d'autres pays occidentaux
souhaiteraient utiliser ce gazoduc comme
levier de sanctions contre moscou mais
les sociaux démocrates qui sont opposés
ce qui n'est pas très surprenant puisque
ce sont justement les sociaux démocrates
avec l'ancien chancelier gerhard
schröder qui ont lancé ce projet avec
vladimir poutine gerhard schröder l'ex
chancelier qui est par ailleurs
désormais la tête du comité
d'actionnaires de la société qui
exploite ce gazoduc mais aussi à la tête
du conseil d'administration du géant
pétrolier russe rosneft il ya donc
encore des liens économiques entre bobo
secours et berlin qui ne sont pas
négligeables comme pour le constater